[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof hello again walter
good day young friend how are you doing
i'm doing well and you
no i'm doing fine i see there were lots
of comments about our
set yes right and i said it was a
conspiracy
but actually i think it was all your
fault yes unfortunately
maybe we must miss just clarify some
things i think so we were just uh
joking around a bit about the set and we
were part of
putting the set together and choosing
the chairs
and it's quite comfortable yeah it's
quite comfortable we've been raised a
little bit so that we have
more arm movement and perhaps we can
also say
you know we live in a country that
is struggling at the moment and things
are not readily available you have to
take what there is this is the best we
could do
under the circumstances and uh
i think it looks all right and it's it's
quite comfortably especially now that
we're a little bit raised
and the important thing is the
discussion yes
it's all about message so
let's jump right into it we need to pray
because we're going to talk about the
road to petition it's closer than you
think
yes i'll pray for you you will pray for
us
our heavenly father ah lord we want to
thank you for bringing us together again
we want to
thank you for all the blessings that you
give us and lord we need you more
and more every day we need you in this
discussion
please enlighten our minds with the holy
spirit is our prayer in jesus name
amen amen perhaps i can just
say thank you to the viewers for keeping
us all on our toes
for those questions and
you can understand that it's almost
impossible for us to answer all the
questions so thank you for all the
people that are trying to answer for us
that's very kind of you
and we will have regular question and
answer sessions to try and address
those things that are problematic
and that people have questions about but
today we're going to talk about
events again as they are occurring in
the world
interesting events yes so why have we
titled it the road to petition it's
closer than you think
because martin there's a tendency in the
world
to be so blatantly contrary
to the word of god and the more blatant
these things become the closer we
are yes towards the end
like in our previous episode in episodes
we've seen creationism
anything it's blatantly being negated
absolutely people are looking
at the world and they are experience
what we call
apocalypse anxiety and there are some
strange things happening
in the world and uh there are strange
phenomena in the skies and
people are just maybe hypersensitive
maybe not but it's interesting the
destruction of jerusalem
serves as a type for the final
destruction
and there were strange phenomena in the
skies
and in the atmosphere in those days
and the world is experiencing similar
things today
so let's have a look at this little
video and see what people have to say
and tonight we're hearing that waking up
to what looked like life on mars is
taking a toll on a lot of people's
mental health and plenty of folks told
kpix 5's joe vasquez
this eerie scene is giving them
apocalypse anxiety joe
yeah liz right now we're at cafe trieste
in north beach
it's 11 o'clock at night it's dark it's
supposed to be at night
but let me show you some video that i
shot earlier today this is
10 o'clock in the morning in this very
same spot
nearly as dark with a tangerine sky
i mean this is otherworldly unlike
anything i've ever seen
and for a lot of people it was
unsettling
ominous ominous and bleak today's creepy
orange sky
made a strong impression it just kind of
feels like the sky is falling and
it's heavy some people told me they felt
unsettled
all day distracted anxious
it's apocalyptic i honestly feel like
we're under attack or something this is
very unusual this is unprecedented i
think for
anyone therapist kat howiter says she is
not surprised people are feeling
uneasy i mean i would say it's a pretty
healthy reaction
we're wired to have a what what is this
reaction to something that
is potentially dangerous and especially
something that's very new so we're not
sure how to cope with it
while it can be explained by science
haliter says it's natural if people have
an outsized reaction to seeing
orange where there should be blue
considering the low-grade trauma we've
all been experiencing this year
especially because of covet 19 howiter
says our isolation is taking away some
of our usual coping mechanisms
still adapting to strange norms has
gotten us
this far yeah it feels like one more
thing and also
everything passes time will continue on
this will pass at some point joe vasquez
kpix 5.
it'll stop and we'll carry on
but there is a point when it will really
stop
when god will intervene and
things will change now we're not
governed and run by experiences such as
these
our standard and our norm is the word of
god right
correct but it's nevertheless
interesting
to see that people are
concerned and notice that there is
something
strange happening in the world
definitely
here is another interview and this one
comes from
fox news and it's another bill gates
interview right
let's have a look at that one just to
set some tones
and then we'll see what's happening in
the world
i sat down earlier with bill gates who's
out with a new book
how to avoid a climate disaster and we
began with the troubles in texas
these last few days the governor
says that wind turbines especially
failed and created this crisis your
response
well it's not not at all true the
failure to weatherize
some of the nuclear sensors the natural
gas plants and even some of the wind
are responsible for their power shortage
and the wind is a tiny part of it
it was mostly the thermal generators
that went offline because they haven't
been weatherized
obviously wind works in north dakota it
works in alaska
we know how to weatherize wind turbines
the wind does come and go
but what was shut down the vast majority
is thermal plants here
uh so you know the there is
there is a reliability issue uh that
will have to design
the system including more transmission
uh you know texas over time will want to
connect up
so that when it does uh get shortages
it's able to draw in other parts of the
country and what happens
if we don't make it if we don't get to
zero
net emissions by 2050 what
how will our daily lives be different
well the migration that we saw
out of syria for their civil war which
was
somewhat weather dependent we're going
to have
10 times as much migration because the
equatorial areas will become unlivable
you won't
be able to farm or go outside
during the summer the wildfires the
you know even the farming productivity
in the south of the u.s the droughts
will uh reduce productivity very
dramatically
and you know it's all a matter of degree
if we wait 10 more years
it's not as bad as if you wait 20 or you
wait 30
because the temperature just keeps going
up and it's going up more rapidly than
it
has in natural history but the
instability overall
will be five times as many deaths at the
peak of the pandemic and going up every
year
martin i have to be very careful how i
phrase things
but the world is very fortunate to have
such an expert around
now he's a an expert in electro
engineering
climate expert it's amazing
and he has the figures down pat it will
be 10 times worse
five times worse farming will become
impossible and he has the time frames
attached to it as well i don't know
what we would do without him
now for those who think that i'm serious
i'm not
but nevertheless what is your take on
that
there's something interesting also for
me that you have to
remember there's an articles that show
that
bill gates is now the biggest um farm
owner
agricultural farm owner in the in
america
and so he has invested vast amounts of
money
into agricultural land yes that's
interesting isn't it
interesting in the previous episode we
saw that he wants is
part of that project that wants to spray
the atmosphere and so he's very
um involved in all the in everything
if if it has to do with a pandemic is
involved if it has to do with climate
change he's involved
now is he a one-man show or do you think
there's a vast
team that is supporting him i think
there's a vast team
there's a vast team and so he's getting
his input
and if we look at all these connections
let's not go there people will say we're
speaking conspiracies
but it's just one of the shows in the
world
where you have this calamity prediction
that is putting it onto a worldly level
with vast amounts of money going
into specific projects and
we are looking at the same history and
the same developments using this book
yeah as our guideline
and this book has not heard yet whereas
some of these gentlemen i think
certainly
will have heard and will be shown
to have heard in the future
another thing that was just interesting
to me is he's very careful of putting
the blame on the wind turbines
this alternative energy so she
is actually pushing the alternative
energy but as we will see
in many areas in the world the
alternative energy
is failing under certain weather
conditions
right which just goes to show that you
cannot
push the world totally into one
direction
because circumstantials might be so that
that would be as detrimental
as the status quo and will lead to
more disasters and sometimes i think
that god is smiling from heaven and when
they think that they have something
pat and they're going in one direction
at a speed
there's just a slight twist instead of
global warming you have
global cooling at such a rate that
nothing that they planned
works anymore i mean i remember them
showing how
france would be a desert like the sahara
and how well he too referred to how
some areas will become such that there
will be no
food production and as people are going
out of business
these mega companies are just buying up
the land
buying up the resources and eventually
the little man will be out of business
and big tech and big business
will be the ones in control we'll be
back
at the same model that prevailed in the
middle ages
where you had the land owners and you
had
this populist the serfs and you had
church and stayed together that's where
we're heading
so let's have a look at how these people
are discussing these things here's the
texas tribune and it says
no frozen wind turbines aren't the main
culprit for texas's power outages
frozen wind turbines in texas caused
some conservative state politicians to
declare tuesday that the state was
relying
too much on renewable energy
but in reality the wind power was
expected to make up only a fraction of
what the state had planned
for during the winter while wind power
skeptics claimed the weeks freeze
means wind power can't be relied upon
wind turbines like the natural gas
plants
can be winterized or modified to operate
during
very low temperatures that's basically
what
bill gates was talking about so maybe he
read the texas tribune
and here's cnn which says frozen wind
turbines
limited gas supplies and rolling
blackouts behind
texas energy woes
rolling power blackouts were ordered
across texas on monday as a winter storm
and of
frigid temperatures gripped the state
and knocked out
service to more than four million
customers
frozen wind turbines and limited gas
supplies
have hampered the ability to generate
enough power
according to the statement from ercot
so here again they are blaming
the infrastructure correct
here's an interesting one from world
news era
germany's green energy failure
germany turns back to coal and natural
gas as
millions of its solar panels are
blanketed
in snow and ice well this is to be
expected isn't it
so germany is in the forefront when it
comes to solar energy
and when you travel there through the
countryside you just
see miles of these solar banks
but they can't work if they're covered
in snow
so there must be a way to constantly
clear them which is not always possible
in the kind of weather that they're
having at the moment
so what is the solution there's always
this idea
that we can change the world and have
one solution
and then there's a spanner in the works
and you realize there isn't
one solution for all of these things
basically the problems will be here
until the end you cannot solve them
there are too many variables correct
so germany faces a sober reality as
millions of its solar panels are
blanketed in snow and ice and
breathless the freezing weather has
rendered its 30
000 wind turbines to idleness
it is not just the wind turbines solar
panels
covered with snow are also rendered
useless so that's what basically we are
saying
it's all coming back to there's a point
why are we showing all of this because
now
this is the blaming game it's either the
alternative energy everything but it's
all coming back to
climate change climate change is going
to be the problem and we need to solve
the climate change
yes so whether it's either too cold or
whether
it's too hot we have to find a climate
change
solution and this is becoming the
catastrophe yes
there must be a culprit right
texas blackouts show how vulnerable
power grid is
to climate change so here is the crux of
the matter
so we're going to have these calamities
they're going to get worse
millions of people will be affected and
in the end there's one button that you
can push
and that button says climate change
so here is an interesting discussion
with schumer
and this is an msnbc
discussion and let's hear what schumer
had to say oh can i say one other thing
on cloud please
i think it might be a good idea for
president biden to call a climate
emergency
why because then he can it's relates to
what you're saying
then he can do many many things under
the emergency powers
of the president that wouldn't have to
go through that he could do without
legislation
now trump used this emergency for a
stupid wall which wasn't an emergency
but if there ever was an emergency
climate is one so i would
suggest that they explore
looking at climate as an emergency which
would give them more flexibility after
all it's a crisis it's a crisis
so you're talking about passing major
climate legislation through the
reconciliation
process it uh pressuring the president
or asking the president to
just ask him let them look at it you
know i have a lot of faith in that he'll
make they'll make a good and right
decision
that sounds to me in terms of the way
you are thinking about that i know
you're thinking about a lot of different
things at once but it sounds like
climate is central in terms of what you
are central
so this is where we're heading right
correct climate so we've had a covet
crisis
that has shown the world how we need to
cooperate
on a universal scale the crisis
is a continuing one the pope has linked
it
to climate change correct now we have
wind turbines stopping we have solar
panels no longer operating because of a
global freeze in a global
warming society and now
the culprit has to be addressed so that
is the big pandemic
so we've now heard from schumer now
let's hear
what john kerry has to say
uh he's come a long way in politics
right correct he comes
and climate change climate change very
important
and this issue has been brewing for a
long time and he's of course very well
connected
being a member of skull and bones and
all of these societies
so let's hear what he has to say how
high
a priority is the climate issue that's
the issue right
the stakes on climate change just simply
couldn't be
any higher than they are right now it is
existential we use that word too easily
we throw it away but we have
a big agenda in front of us on a global
basis
and president biden is deeply committed
totally seized by this issue as you can
tell by this executive order
he also knows that paris alone is not
enough
not when almost 90 percent of all of the
planet's emissions
global emissions come from outside of
u.s borders
we could go to zero tomorrow and the
problem isn't solved
so that's why today one week into the
job president biden
will sign this additional executive set
of orders
to help move us down the road ensuring
that ambitious climate action
is global in scope and scale
as well as the national here at home
the president is announcing that he will
host a leaders summit
on climate change less than three months
from now
on april 22nd earth day which will
include a leader
level reconvening of the major economies
forum
to the convening of this uh of this
summit is essential to ensuring
that the that 2021 is going to be the
year that really makes up for the lost
time of the last four years
and that the un climate conference cop
26 as it's called
which the uk is hosting in november
uh to make sure that it is an
unqualified success
so how high is it on his agenda top
top and it's going to be
universal universal not only
in america and the last four years were
wasted according to him
now we're going to move in that
direction you can almost say that
they want to change gears and if this
last freeze created such a calamity
because there were apparently relying
too much on
alternative energy if they push that
further along and there is another
calamity
then we will have very similar
experiences just escalated to what we
had
during the covet
when there was some statements that the
lockdowns that we experienced
under covert would be nothing
compared to the lockdowns we might
experience under
climate legislation so this is a very
interesting way in which the world is
moving correct
and along with all of this there will be
legislation
absolutely you know it's interesting
that he got into trouble for using his
private jet
right i mean that's a tremendous
emission that he's putting out into the
world
and just tongue-in-cheek let's see what
he had to say about that
new data shows that kerry's private jet
has raked in frequent flyer miles in
recent years including
a 2019 trip to iceland
and here's the funny part he went to
iceland to accept an award for climate
leadership when asked about the
hypocrisy at the time back in 2019
here's how mr carey responded
it's the only choice for somebody like
me the time it takes me to get somewhere
i can't sail across the ocean i have to
fly
to meet with people and get things done
but what i'm doing
almost full time is working to win the
battle
of climate change i'm not going to be
put on the defensive
so wasn't bill gates also confronted
because he was using
private jets for his activities what was
his answer well his answer was
he spends a lot of invests a lot of
money in green housing
and so he's trying to equal it out about
so it offsets his office his his private
jet
marvelous so if you have a lot of money
and you can invest in greenhouses then
you can use a private jet yeah
well here is this article i was
referring to in the spectator
are you ready for the climate lockdowns
it's only a matter of time
this is where it's heating this is where
it's heading right this is the next
phase in human history
the possibility of climate lockdowns is
already being
floated by some of our greatest thinkers
they see a confluence of global crisis
as an
opportunity under a climate lockdown
governments would limit private vehicle
use
ban consumption of red meat
and impose extreme energy saving
measures now i find it interesting
that bill gates invested quite a fortune
into the alternative meat and
energy he also invested in the beyond
meat
industry so they're way ahead of us
right
by the way this is not an investment tip
this is an apocalyptic
discussion so let's stick to the
the theme so that we're going to impose
extreme energy saving
measures while fossil fuel companies
would have to stop drilling
to avoid such a scenario we must
overhaul our economic structures
and do capitalism differently
carl lauterbach an mp of the german
social democratic party
wrote in developed last december that we
need
measures to deal with climate change
that are similar to the restrictions on
personal
freedom imposed to combat
the pandemic so
the restrictions on personal freedom
are actually locked in
to this program and the vaccination is
very important and many many countries
including the vatican
yes have now decided that if you do not
go with this program you will not be
able to work any longer
so there is a channeling and a funneling
of humanity
in a particular direction we've spoken
about that
a lot here's another article
aoc and bernie sanders pushed joe biden
to declare
a climate emergency with a new bill
so schumer asked for it we saw the
interview
now bernie sanders and uh as trump
called them the freshmen
are asking for the same thing so this is
very interesting we are
on this roller coaster and we're heading
in a direction
and we are talking apocalyptic yes
so the legislation introduced by
senator bernie sanders and jeff merkley
and representative alexandria
ocasio-cortez
and earl blumenauer on thursday would
require
president joe biden to declare a
national emergency on climate change
that would give the administration more
power to take on the
existential threat including deploying
the necessary
resources to do so the massive scope and
scale of action
necessary to stabilize the climate will
require
unprecedented levels of public awareness
engagement and deliberation to develop
and implement effective
just and equitable policies to address
the climate
crisis the act says now
we have predicted early in the covet
crisis
that this would be the next step yes
this was just a stepping stone to this
reality
and we've always linked it to the papal
encyclical lauda to see
with all that that entails
here's another article international
lawyers
propose ecocide to criminalize
environmental destruction so now we need
laws in place that will
streamline any action that is taken and
any
anything that is decided with regard to
climate change must become
universal lawn we've seen this
in the covet crisis there were lockdowns
mass great regulations social
distance regulations and so there will
be
regulations regarding this issue as well
you're not allowed to do this you're not
allowed to do that there were
certain shopping times that were
implemented under covet
do you think there will be certain times
that will be allocated as well
certain industry-free days
could that be sunday legislation that is
in the pipeline
and anybody who doesn't comply to these
laws
becomes a danger to society
he's acting contrary to the common good
good
correct so several international
law experts are seeking to approve a new
crime
called ecocide which allow
authorities to take action against
environmental destruction
so if you partake in activities on a day
that has been declared as essential
for controlling the climate then you
would be guilty of ecocide right yes
you'll be transgressing the law so if
approved environmental crimes will
become icc's
fifth jurisdictional responsibility
teen climate activist greater thornburg
has supported the implementation of the
law
and french president emmanuel macron
have also hinted at incorporating
ecocide into the domestic law
of the country with such powerful
individuals involved there's no way that
this is not going to happen
right yes calling the environmental
damages
sins of ecology that's very
interesting that's bringing it
towards the bible theologically yes so
there's a theological twist to it right
so now we have a new definition of sin
the definition of sin is transgression
of the law
law there's only one definition in the
bible
when it comes to sin what is sin
and that's god's law and that's god's
law this sins of ecology is
transgression of the ecology law this is
pope francis
who has said that his understanding of
ecocide
is the massive contamination of air land
and water resources the large-scale
destruction of flora and fauna and any
action
capable of producing an ecological
disaster or destroying an ecosystem
that's ecocide but the definition will
be
broad now under the covet
circumstances
there were many people that felt it
their duty to report
anyone that wasn't actually living
in harmony with the new legislation
right
and we saw some terrible things
happening i mean
people just shooting people because they
weren't wearing a mask or weren't
wearing it correctly
or vice versa i mean there were some
horrible incidences
and spying on people became
part of the game here's an interesting
discussion on
sky news australia and
it says that the tory is unhappy over
new
spying laws everyone i've spoken to has
been horrified
by it when it has been explained to them
so what is this all about
spying let's just have a look at this
little video
it will allow 16 and 17 year olds to spy
on their parents it also authorizes them
to commit
crimes as well so it needs to be
extremely tightly
controlled and those controls need to be
greater than what the government is
proposing
and as you were saying this um covert
human intelligence bill
allows for some pretty shocking things
including
encouraging or recruiting 16 and 17 year
olds
legally children to spy on their parents
and to commit crimes
in the process of spying on their
parents if they think if there's a
strong suspicion
that their parents are up to no good
what are they supposed to be spying on
well that's the it's interesting you
raised that question so the this bill
would be to spy on people who are
suspected of
fairly serious crimes um drug dealing
maybe terrorism things that obviously no
one should be doing but what's really
interesting is the left in this country
is actually quite critical of this bill
but the left of course supports uh
children spying on their parents as well
there have been numerous campaigns over
the past few years where children have
been encouraged to
watch their parents environmental
behavior and to report them to schools
if their parents aren't being
eco-friendly
or you know children are there's a new
bill going through in scotland which
would make it potentially
a crime to commit hate speech in your
own home
which openly encourages children to
squeal their parents to the police
if they are islamophobic or transphobic
or whatever else
so what we have now is both the right
and the left in different ways support
children spying on their own families
martin this has been part of history for
a very very long time
i once gave a lecture which was called
the herodian mind perhaps you can put a
link
in it's part of your series clash of
mines clash of mines yes
and in that in that lecture i
showed how king herod had a huge
spy network and where he used this
method of putting citizens against each
other
your neighbor becomes the spy that
watches what you are doing
your own children become the spies
and of course this has been implemented
by many many nations
communist nations mao zeitung
adolf hitler all of these have
incorporated these
massive spy networks that make use of
this
snitching and it has caused
untold pain in the course of history
and this is a method that is also
employed
by the societies that deal with
espionage in the world
and you have all the major espionage
organizations in the various countries
of the world
and they are tied to the vatican
there was a there was a whistleblower
some time ago by the name of karen hodus
and she was highly upset of how
the finances were run and that the
jesuits were in control
of the bank of america and how
the the secret services fell under
the vatican's secret service the vatican
has the
greatest mechanism of spying
on people and individuals that the world
has ever seen and all of this
is coming together and is in harmony
with
what this book says about
the end times doesn't the bible say that
the members of your own household will
turn against each other
yes these will be the rules that will be
enforced you won't be safe
in your environment you will not be
safe even your closest neighbors
and maybe members of your own family
will be the ones that will hand you over
if you do not comply with all of these
laws
now i agree that you must comply
with the laws of government except
where they are in conflict with god's
law but we'll deal with that as we go on
here is the burkian it has an article
roxanne ireland's new anti-hate speech
surveillance technology
a biometrics based platform ostensibly
to monitor and crack down on organized
crime an additional application of
roxanne
which its creators advertise freely
is the ability to monitor those guilty
of alleged hate speech and political
extremism
now our last what's up dealt with
political extremism so if you believe
as miller believed then you are an
extremist correct
right well the field test
was trialled solely on phone calls
roxanne is advertised as also being able
to uncover the creators of so-called
hate or propaganda speech no matter the
platform
this is all occurring in the context of
enhanced surveillance on right-wing
groups across europe
with german authorities likely to rule
in favor of allowing security forces
to formally put the nation's primary
opposition party
the afd under surveillance for alleged
extremism
this month they're dealing now with
specific organizations
but this can become universal
and blanket any aspect you can even link
the climate change into this everything
can eventually be linked into this
and we also know what the bible says
will be the final
group of people that this will be used
upon
correct that's what we spoke about so
here's a little diagram
which shows how the networks are going
to be
analyzed bi-directional information flow
increased security speech processing
natural language processing video and
geographical
meta data processing everything you say
everything you do everything on your
social media platform whether you use a
computer
phone but we know this already so we
don't have to spend a lot of time on it
maybe there used to be some skeptics
and i think they have something to
ponder upon
when they see these yes yes there's a
lot of skepticism about
do they really do this do the mega tech
companies
really spy on the you isn't it just to
sell you a product we're very naive when
we believe that right
i mean there have been enough
congressional
uh investigations regarding this issue
and the answers have always been
uh vague can put it mildly i mean you've
got this big
let's name it controversial the bank of
america
that gave all that information now with
the people that were around
washington dc on the 6th of january
correct and if they can
silence an ex-president or even an
acting president
how much more the little man right
so lockdown says the times is turning us
into a nation of spies
it's been a revelation to discover how
ready britons are to spy
on report and judge those around them
in this pandemic almost 200
000 reports of lockdown breaches had
been made to the police by the end of
april
exhausting many forces capacity to
respond
several forces pleaded with the public
to deal directly with transgressions
themselves if they could do so safely
involving police only for the most
serious ones it's all the more curious
because for the past couple of decades
there's been a public reluctance to be
seen to judge
others there's a turnaround right
why because there's a cause correct and
if you have convinced people
that the cause is real then people will
be willing to act on it and so
if you have convinced people that the
common good
is the cause that everything has to go
by
there's also a quote in the spirit of
prophecy that at the in the end
there will be a decree going out that
people will be able
to take the law into their own hands
absolutely and this is exactly
where we are going they're even
encouraging it here
here's the the official web page of the
uk police and
they are just blatantly asking tell us
about a possible breach of coronavirus
covet 19 measures
tell us about it we want to know who is
the culprit
so we will have similar things in regard
to climate
definitely do you think that if there is
a lockdown day
that there will be spies all around
to see whether you comply or not
absolutely absolutely
now what i find particularly fascinating
is how the legislation is moving
forward and what is particularly
alarming
is how religion is being incorporated
in that legislation
here is an article in evangelical
focus and it says france includes
religious
views in police files of potential
extremists so philosophical and
religious convictions
will be described in records of
thousands of people
who are seen as a threat to the state
evangelicals worried about the fragility
of fundamental rights
so religion is being incorporated in
this legislation
in the last what's-ups we looked at
the q anon issue and how adventists in
particular
are going to be targeted as
extremists in this regard let's see how
this pans out
as of november 2020 these three types of
governmental
files had registered information
of over 300 000 people according to the
official data
nevertheless the gathering of extra
information will only be allowed in the
cases of
individuals seen as likely to harm
the fundamental interests of the nation
we're talking about common good correct
so
if climate change is a law
then fall under this it will affect the
fundamental interests of the nation
the integrity of the nation or the
institutions of the republic
or those who constitute a terrorist
threat now how wide is that definition
correct very broad this also includes
now
religion correct
now martin what was the title of our
discussion
road to petition road to petition
it's closer than you think it's closer
than you think
this one from february 2021
is really very interesting
french minister of the interior says
evangelicals are a very important
problem so now we're not talking about
islamic fundamentalism
we're talking about evangelicals
evangelical churches increasingly
worried about unfair attacks of the
government
this after all is the evangelical focus
that is reporting here
let's read this because i think this is
one of the
key issues of our time
evangelical christians in france are
expressing
unease as they see how the national
government inflames the rhetoric
against their churches the last episode
has to do with the words of the french
minister of the interior gerald
d'armanin in an interview with tv
broadcaster c
news he said quote
evangelicals are a very important
problem only to add quote
obviously not of the same nature
than the islamism that makes terrorist
attacks
and deaths so there's a difference but
they're a problem
why one day before speaking about
the controversial anti-separatism law
that is expected to be passed soon he
told radio broadcaster france inter
quote we cannot discuss with people
who refuse to write on paper that the
law
of the republic is superior
to the law of god
that is a thunderous statement
this man this minister of the interior
wants people to write that the law
of the republic stands higher than the
law
of god who is he attacking god
he's attacking god i wonder whether he
has
any concept of history if he reads the
bible if you look at what happened when
the assyrians
attacked judea what did that
representative of the
syrian king have to say
didn't he attack god's authority yes
absolutely directly here this man is
attacking
god's authority directly and he is
attacking god's law
that's a that's a major it's major
does he remember what happened to france
when they got rid of religion and
enthroned the goddess of reason
which of course is a jesuit theology
reason informed by faith is what they
talk about
here you have exactly the same thing you
take god
out of the picture and create your own
legislation
you could just lose the heads of the
cream
of your country correct literally
literally yes so this man
is attacking god's law and saying
that the law of the world and of
the country stands higher than god's law
in fact you cannot reason with people
that claim that god's law has the
highest authority
they are extremists they are in danger
so they can use the spying network that
we were talking about
previously or earlier to pinpoint people
that says god's law is higher than the
law of the republic
correct now let's think about this
logically
we're talking about major climate
problems in the world we're talking
about climate legislation
we're talking about laws that could come
into conflict with god's law
because you cannot reason with people
that claim that god's law is higher than
any other law
so which law
could be affected is it
thou shalt not kill no no
is it thou shalt not steal no is it any
one of those laws
most of the laws are based on logical
premises
absolutely so which law could come into
conflict
with god's law a day of worship a day of
worship
it's the only one it's the only one that
will come into conflict
here's another one australian christians
say they'll defy
ban on prayer for overcoming unwanted
sexual attractions now this is
on a totally different level it deals
with the different
issues it deals with gender
identification
but we're not discussing that we're just
discussing the implications right what
is this law
all about the change or suppression
conversion practices prohibition bill
has now passed through both houses of
the victorian
parliament it forbids any attempt to
change
or suppress or induce any person
to change or suppress his or her sexual
orientation
or gender identity prayer
or counseling designed to change a
person
even at that person's request
is prohibited in short this means that
sexual preference is protected by law
as is any person's gender preference
homosexual sex is not permitted to be
called
sin and a male today
can claim to be a female tomorrow
barnes said significantly the victorian
legislation
makes it illegal for a parent to pray
for their own child even if they had
requested them to do so as such
dr barnes believes that it is right for
christians to defy the governing
authorities
such as when king darius
exceeded his god-given authority daniel
did
as he had done previously powell wrote
so the point is not whether the gender
issue is correct or
incorrect in their view the point is
they are
legislating whether you may pray or not
correct and what you are allowed to pray
about
that is scary to say the least this is
arrogance of the highest order this is
defying the god of the bible
directly so the french government
has decided to defy god directly
and now here in victoria
they've decided exactly the same thing
god is the one who defines what sin is
yes not they but they have taken the
prerogative upon themselves
to define what sin is and to legislate
against those who believe that god has
the final say
who are they attacking god directly
question
what happened when the assyrians did
exactly
that 185 000
wiped out were wiped out they had
reached the point of no return
martin i believe the world is
speeding towards the point
of no return it has now turned into
open defiance against god's
authority correct and also what's being
defied
is god gave you freedom of choice
correct there's no freedom of choice in
this no freedom of choice
and how they're going to know whether
you prayed
or whether you did not pray mustn't
there be someone in your household who
can act as a snitch and say
that this person prayed correct
it is to me absolutely mind-boggling
that we should have come to a place in
history
where governments will openly defy
the authority of god
war on the rocks espionage and the
catholic church from the cold war
to the present while the cold war
is over the prominent role of the
catholic church in international affairs
has only expanded the extensive
footprint of papal diplomats around the
world has solidified their place
as valuable members of the international
affairs community the pope does not have
a large
military or a vast economic resources
regardless the holy see will remain
a prime target for espionage
due to its influence and possession of
one of the most
valuable commodities of the present time
accurate and timely information
this is the greatest
espionage organization in the
entire world as karen hood has said in
the past
the vatican espionage organization
is the hub to which all the others
are attached correct and their finger
is throughout all of
humanity we have reached a point
in history where the predictions
in the good book are coming to fruition
before our eyes
now in the past we spoke about
the messianic movements
and that the world is waiting for this
messiah
the savior i mean the news
is so full of people who are absolutely
desperate yes we spoke about it last
time the suicide
since then there have been interviews
with politicians that are concerned
about
the terrible state of humanity
and of the rise of suicide and the
desperateness
so the world is looking for a savior
and now it's interesting to me that the
jewish nation
has now come to this point where it says
the time for the savior
is now now
two thousand years ago there was
a messiah and that messiah paid the
price
on a cross and that messiah was rejected
but now they're waiting for a messiah so
let's just look at this little video
showing what the status quo is right now
[Music]
breaking news a historical world event
is happening just before purim on sunday
february 21st
at the exact same moment all around the
globe an emotional heartfelt call will
arise from all jews to heaven
from a shiite to reveal himself
observant non-observant ashkenazi
sephardic hasaden
all jews as one even you famous jews
let's be the actors witnesses of this
better world
that we so much hope for that's all
um
[Applause]
[Music]
of course i am i have it on my phone
let's say together
master of the universe
prepared
italian
[Music]
opportunity the world is in chaos
the only thing that can really save our
planet
is mashiach the only thing that machias
is waiting for
are our prayers all jews
as one contribute to the sanctification
of hashem's name
[Music]
you know martin this is kind of sad
i was thinking about the same thing this
is very sad indeed because
the world i believe has missed the point
again they are waiting for a savior that
will
set up a temporal millennium
of peace and harmony and restore
all things and
they waited for that the first time
around they're waiting for it the second
time round
and the bible has a totally different
story
and the real messiah will come and he
will restore all things
but prior to that there will be a false
messiah
and according to this thinking he is
already in the world
he just needs to reveal himself
and then the world will enter this age
of peace
now isn't it interesting that they're
praying this year
they want this to happen john kerry said
that this year 2021 is the great
opportunity
schumer said 2021 now is the time when
we need emergency
legislation biden has said there will be
summits on earth day in april
in this year then there will be the
coming together of the nations
united nations united nations 2021
2021 also the commemoration of the 1700
years
of sunday legislation
the great economical push taking place
after that to bring this to the
economical movement
this idea that sunday should be
introduced again
and should be sustained as it was in the
days of constantine
all of this happening in 2021
and they're wanting their messiah to
come
maybe all these things that we are
showing can encourage our viewers
to reach out to these people
because we know that there is who is the
true
savior that's coming yes and why is
coming yes
because not to bring temporal peace but
to put an end
to sin and this message has to go out
correct now we spoke about some of these
things in the past now
this might look as if we're going off
topic but actually we're not
here is a very interesting article
or document that was placed by the world
bank
and it said there for official use only
and
this is just to show what the document
looks like
it was put out in on april the 2nd
2020 and we'll just hone
in on one section and see what this
pertains to
here is the link and it dealt with
the covert crisis right the program
development objective is to prevent
detect and respond to the threat posed
by covet 19
and strengthen national systems for
public health
preparedness and it's interesting that
they
approved the project on the 2nd of april
2012 this is the world bank
this is a major institution now when did
they
expect this covet crisis
or this project to come to
an end expected project closing date
the 31st of march 2025.
that's interesting they already
on the 2nd of april 2020 a point
that this would reach unto the 31st of
march 2025 that's pretty specific isn't
it
yes pretty specific expect a program
closing date 31st of march 2025.
now my question is did they just grab
this
out of a hat i doubt it very seriously
i don't know i can only speculate yeah
but be that as it may isn't that
interesting that in a previous one we
also discussed
alice a bailey and the externalization
of the hierarchy
in plain language when the demons would
manifest
themselves as the saviors of humanity
that that was to take place somewhere in
now i'm not saying that it will no i
don't know
i'm just quoting what alisay bailey says
here the world bank
says that the closing date is in 2020
and they're all waiting for the messiah
whether that will be earlier or later
i don't know the fact of the matter is
we are speeding towards the events
predicted in the bible amen
here's another article from the
evangelical focus
pope francis the chaplain of the united
nations
so he has basically been elevated to
this position
of high authority the bible speaks about
this
now we get a lot of people that say why
do you always speak about the papers
yes and i'm wondering do these people
read their bibles
have they read the book of revelation do
they know
who is defined there in the bible
as the great opponent to god
and that the world should be warned
against this power
and they believe that you should not say
a word about it
it astounds me perhaps people
that are so concerned about this should
just carry on with their daily lives
and not look at these programs right
maybe that will be easier for them maybe
that'll be easier let them be warned
that need to be warned and those that
want to be complacent
let them continue to be complacent
now martin why is the pope so important
that he becomes the chaplain in the
minds of the people at least
of the united nations broader than just
the organization
we're talking about the world's nations
why are all eyes directed towards him
it's because he covers all the bases
right it's not
only religious yes he speaks about
climate change he speaks about economy
inclusive capitalism he covers all bases
and he talks about fraternity the
brotherhood of humanity
and the common good so if you look at
this it says these 2020 universal
initiatives indeed look like those of
the united nations in language
scope and content we're all brothers
everybody is exactly the same doesn't
matter
what religion you belong to all roads
lead to heaven
that's contrary to what jesus said yes
there's only one way
to heaven then the global compact on
education
this is the u.n globalist language
but the roman catholic language
significantly overlaps with it
as you say the the education
the new education re-education
and then the economy of francesco the
goal is to strive towards a pact to
change the current economy
and to give new soul to the global
economy
and that's where the world economic
forum comes in you will own nothing
we've said it many many times
and as we said last time that is
prefigured in the story of joseph
where pharaoh eventually
possesses everything and the citizen
nothing but what i left out last time
it's interesting that that did not
affect
the clergy yes it didn't affect the
the religious world and when you read
the roman catholic economic plan
you will see that roman catholic
property is not affected by
any government confiscation
of land not at all so exactly
what happened in the time of joseph
joseph
will be repeated in this world
now let's just have a look at this
little video here
where pope francis is speaking and all
the religions
of the world are at his feet
[Music]
sienna
is
[Music]
foreign
the
[Music]
others
now martin this sounds very good
sounds very nice but the gospel
of salvation in christ alone has been
eviscerated
removed completely
this gospel must be preached to all
nations and all the world
the whole world and then the end will
come
here is a movement that totally negates
the gospel
this exclusive salvation in
one universal savior has been removed
all roads lead to heaven according to
this discussion
is this contrary to the will of christ
yes and
that's what when i we're looking at the
video
thinking
if you look at this you think it sounds
so good
it actually sounds biblical almost
because you have to love your neighbor
as you love yourself
correct how do you love your neighbor
don't you love your neighbor if you warn
him
of the precipice to come yes because
this love your neighbor
excludes jesus actually correct
and another thing that i also would like
to add
this is what's sad for me
with people saying you should stop
focusing the whole time on what the pope
says
because the bible warns us that that
will be the entity that brings
all the all things together
against what will happen against christ
actually
this is a war on christ so let us look
at this
revelation chapter 13 verse 3
and i saw one of his heads as it were
wounded to death
and his deadly wound was healed and
all the world wandered after the beast
now we know who the beast is
there is not a shadow of doubt as to who
the beast is it is the roman catholic
system
all the reformers said it the bible is
absolutely clear on this issue there is
not a shadow of doubt
and it says that the whole world
wandered
after the beast now if you take this
little word wandered
and you look it up in the strong's
concordance
and there is the word as it appears in
the greek and what does it mean
to wonder by implication to admire
admire have an admiration marvel
wonder so
it's not walking after the beast it is
a universal admiration
of the papal system do we see that yes
is it prevalent at the level of the
united nations correct
yes do the religious
people in the world radiate towards yes
did the president of the united states
say that he wants to
implement the thinking of this power
100 correct and then
the instrumentalities such as john kerry
the political system are they linked
to the papacy in their secret societies
and even in their public affiliations
yes
and their agenda of climate change is
also linked
with the pope he wrote a whole
encyclical on the climate
and on fraternity so let's read this
again and i saw one of the heads
as it were wounded to death he lost his
power right
and his political clout had been removed
and the deadly wound was healed
he again received this political
acclamation
and all the world wandered
by implication admired
this power
in revelation 17 verse 6 we get a little
bit more information
and i saw the woman that's the church
this is rome the church of rome
drunken with the blood of the saints
and with the blood of the martyrs of
jesus and when i saw her
i wandered with great admiration
now this is the prophet of god he's
looking at this system that is receiving
such recognition in the world
that the whole world admires this system
and he wondered wondered
with great admiration but not in a
positive sense
he was stunned yes that this power
that was drunk with the blood of the
saints
that this power that had slaughtered the
martyrs of
jesus should receive such admiration
so you have a different admiration here
definitely this is the same type of
admiration
that i think we sit with now that's the
kind of admiration that we have
we're wondering how is this possible
in the light of history and if we and
just to say this but
if we don't show this to the people out
there
they complain now that we do this all
the time the whole time
we have to it's our job to this is the
job because this is the
beast that everybody will be wandering
after and if you don't
know this beast you're going to be
included
let's just go back to history w e h leki
says the following of this system
referring to this verse
that the church of rome has shed more
innocent blood
than any other institution that has ever
existed amongst mankind
will be questioned by no protestant who
has a competent
knowledge of history the memorials
indeed of many of her persecutions
are now so scanty that it is impossible
to form
a complete conception of the multitude
of her victims
and it is quite certain that no power of
imagination can adequately realize
their sufferings she now covers her
deeds with
soft sweet words packages them in a way
that receives the admiration of the
world
but she's no less this power than she
was
when she snuffed out the lives of god's
people
she is what the bible says she is she is
the antichrist system
now when we go to scripture this word
wondered
is very interesting if you go to luke
chapter 4 verse 21
referring to jesus and he began to say
unto them this day
is the scripture fulfilled in your ears
he was reading out of the book of isaiah
right and luke 4 verse 22
says and all bear him witness and
wondered at the gracious
words which proceeded out of his mouth
and they said is this not joseph's son
so here is another power where people
wandered they admired what he was saying
and they were saying how can such
gracious words
come out of his mouth isn't he just
joseph's son how's this possible
so you have these two wonders
the world wandered after the beast
admired it
listened to the words which flowed out
of the mouth
and then you have the real messiah
not his so-called representative
and people wondered that the gracious
words
which proceeded out of his mouth and
luke 8 25
says and he said unto them where is your
faith
and they being afraid wondered
saying one unto another what manner of
man is this
for he command us even the winds and the
water
and they obey him
we're talking about the real messiah yes
we're talking about god manifest
in the flesh one command and the waves
were still
never had there been a man with such
authority with such grace
luke 11 verse 14 says and he was casting
out the devil and it was dumb and it
came to pass when the devil was gone out
the dumb spake
and the people wondered
i wish humanity who would spend
more time contemplating wondering
about jesus christ than about
an impostor in rome basically martin
what i'm trying to say is
here is a type of wondering
where you are contemplating the acts and
the
works of christ and you
are absolutely flabbergasted
in the one instance they are
wondering but they are also confused
in the second one over here where he
silences
the waves and the storm they are
overawed
and they are contemplating how is this
possible
what kind of power is there in this man
and when he casts out devils and the
demons obey him
then people are also stunned at what is
happening
so what i'm saying here is the one
that we should contemplate the one that
we should believe
the one that we should follow should
surely be the one who has demonstrated
beyond the shadow of doubt what he
is who he is and what he is capable of
correct now here's another one that's
interesting
luke 9 43 and they were all amazed at
the mighty power of god
but while they wondered
everyone at all things which jesus did
he said unto his disciples let these
sayings sink
down into your ears for the son of man
shall be delivered into the hands of
men just imagine the scene
he's performing the most amazing
miracles
and they are wondering that same word
as to what is happening around them
and then he says let this sink in let
this sink
down into your ears for the son of man
shall be delivered into the hands of men
when you look at him
and you follow him and you believe he's
the messiah
you're thinking about the great future
and he turns around and says the
opposite
and they are stunned
john 15 20 remember the word that i
said unto you the servant is not greater
than his lord
if they have persecuted me they will
also
persecute you if they have kept
my saying they will keep yours
also and in john 16
33 he says these things i have spoken
unto you
that in me you might have peace
in the world ye shall
it's a promise yes have tribulation
but be of good cheer i have overcome the
world
basically what jesus is saying
contemplate who i am
contemplate my capabilities
which prove who i am put your trust
in the one who has demonstrated
that he has the authority
that he has the power and when you do
that
you will be the enemy of the world
wander after that one
wonder after that one don't wander after
the beast
and when you wander after him when you
wander after jesus christ
you will be persecuted you will
have a surveillance system geared
at spying on your every move
there will be legislation passed against
you
his law because he's the one who spoke
the law
yes he's the one who said i've not come
to change the law
not one shot or one tittle will by any
means disappear from the law
until all things have been accompanied
no matter what a french minister or an
australian minister has to say on the
issue
god's word remains paramount
that's our choice we either wander
after the beast and admire it or we
expose it for what it is
and we wander after our lord and savior
jesus christ that is our
choice let's pray
heavenly father the world
is at the crossroads
finally they are speaking in open
defiance against your authority
and lord we know that if we look at the
bible and the history of the children of
israel
that was the signal
for the intervention of god
we are in the final moments of this
earth's history
and i pray that your people will wake up
to this reality in jesus name
amen amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe to our channel
click here to get notifications click on
the bell
to watch the next video click here
thank you and we'll see you again